[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de face aux territoires en
direct sur tv5 monde aujourd'hui bien
sûr cette émission est également
regardable sur les sites de nos
partenaires donc ouest france.fr
nicematin.com 306 point fr lamontagne.fr
et 20 minutes m'ont invité aujourd'hui
c'est jean marc ayrault bonjour jean
marc bonjour merci d'être avec nous vous
êtes bien sûr ancien premier ministre
ancien ministre des affaires étrangères
et vous êtes le président de la
fondation pour la mémoire de l'esclavagé
jean marc ayrault c'est la guerre en
ukraine qui va occuper évidemment la
plupart du temps de cette émission la
situation au septième jour de cette
invasion russe deux phrases ce matin
importante le bilan humain est
ahurissant anthony blinken le secrétaire
d'état américain a déclaré ça il ya
quelques minutes est une déclaration
également de jean yves le drian qui dit
le pire est peut-être devant nous jean
yves le drian qui je le rappelle a été
votre ministre de la défense jean marc
ayrault première question vous avez
approché à multiples de multiples
reprises vladimir poutine on va en
parler tout au long de cette émission y
at il tout de même une responsabilité
des grands leaders de nos gouvernants
dont vous avez fait partie dont vous
faites partie depuis on va dire plus
d'une décennie qui n'ont pas su déceler
qui n'ont pas su voir qu'ils étaient
devenus vladimir poutine
il y aura beaucoup de recul pour pour
comprendre tout ce qui a conduit à cette
tragédie parce que c'est une tragédie
pour le peuple ukrainien nos poutine dit
qu'il n'existe pas est en fait la nation
ukrainienne réagi se défend avec dignité
et avec courage au prix de 2 2 lors de
la vie de beaucoup de gens et quand vous
avez regardé plein manger routine dans
les yeux j'ai rencontré vous allez
dernière fois que je les ai vus c'était
en fin 2013 début de fin 2013 vers la
fin octobre début novembre j'avais la
réunion annuelle drancourt huss
président et par les premiers ministres
s'étaient medvedev est dans le programme
de ma visite à moscou il y avait une
rencontre avec vadim poutine qui m'a
reçu dans sa datcha tout à fait
simplement mais très vite on est rentré
dans le vif du sujet contact tél c'était
c'était assez froid mais sans
agressivité au départ mais très vite ça
l'est devenu ça l'est devenu il y avait
un sujet qui préoccupe est et qui était
centrale dans la content c'était
l'ukraine déjà l'ukraine à cette époque
était envisagée dans les jours qui
suivaient ma visite une réunion de
l'union européenne et de l'ukraine pour
signer un accord d'association
d'association entre l'ukraine et l'union
européenne et poutine n'en voulait pas
et agressé m'agresser agacé la france
agressé l'europe dix ans et en termine
en disant ça ne se fera pas cet accord
ne sera pas signée en fait il n'a pas
été saignée puisqu'il ianoukovitch le
président ukrainien proche de moscou a
cédé à boutines mai mais ce qui s'est
passé je crois que c'est très important
ce qui s'est passé à l'époque c'était
fin 2013 et très vite ça s'est poursuivi
en 2014 c'est la mobilisation populaire
amaidan la place de kiev et où la
population réclamait on veut l'accord
avec l'union européenne c'est à dire que
ça s'est passé avec un mouvement
populaire d'une très grande puissance
avec énormément de répression puis
finalement à la fin le président
ianoukovitch a quitté l'ukraine pour se
rendre en russie accueillis par poutine
et puis finalement l'accord a été signé
quand vous voyez la tête de ces de ses
généraux de son biseau la défense
lorsqu'il a parlé de de passer d'un cran
supérieur et de passer en dissuasion
nucléaire qu'est ce que vous pensez par
bras au fait que vous avez rencontrées
vous vous pensez que le personnage à
avrillé comme on dit s'associe pas parce
que l'on est dans l'explication
psychologique je veux pas me lancer des
révélations de ces fous rires on a vu
les images chacun ce que je voulais
rappeler parce que quand je vous ai dit
que l'accord avec l'union européenne
avait finalement été signé entre
l'ukraine et la l union européenne il ya
une ré une réaction de poutine qui a été
le soutien séparatistes du donbass et la
halle à l'annexion de la crimée ça a été
sa réponse donc il y avait sa propre
logique sa propre logique grand russe sa
propre logique de reconstituer en
quelque sorte l'empiré tsariste et
également de sa de sa de son de son
complément soviétique et c'est sans son
rêve et il n'y est pas arrivé jusqu'à
présent et là on a l'impression d'une
fuite en avant avec une extrême violence
et qui est l'invasion de la deûle de
l'ukraine ça c'est quelque chose de
terrible c'est jean marc ayrault
l'ancien premier ministre qui est notre
invité ce matin d'en face aux
territoires dans un instant
françois-xavier l'offrande hors essence
[Musique]
françois-xavier lefranc vous êtes le
rédacteur en chef du premier quotidien
francophone du monde la guerre en
ukraine toujours encore bonjour monsieur
ayrault bonjour alors on l'histoire
jugera et on se demandera longtemps si
on il aurait été possible d'arrêter ça
la vraie question aujourd'hui c'est est
ce qu'on peut arrêter la guerre et ça
semble absolument impossible on a le
sentiment qu'on est parti dans un
conflit qui sera très long qui sera
extrêmement dur avec un coût humain
terrible c'est le sentiment qu'on a ce
matin que ça ne va pas mais
malheureusement le risque existe que ça
et encore plus loin et que le coût
humain pour les ukrainiens soit
catastrophique il ya déjà un million de
réfugiés c'est l'exode toutes ces images
qui frappent l'opinion publique beaucoup
de gens pensaient que la guerre ne se
produiraient jamais sur le continent
européen et elle est en train d'arriver
et même les jeunes générations
aujourd'hui s'en inquiète et à juste
titre donc c'est quelque chose de
terrible catastrophique mais tout a été
tenté et il faut continuer à le faire
par la voie diplomatique ce que fait
manuel mâcon ce que fait le chansonnier
shops où ce café byden enfin tous ceux
qui ont essayé de discuter avec poutine
ont elles sont allées le plus loin
possible
et puis finalement ils ont eu à faire
face à un mur ou poutine était déterminé
décidé et il est passé à l'acte est
comme une sorte de fuite en avant et ça
s'est pas passé exactement comme il le
souhaitait parce que ça aussi pensé que
ça allait très vite que l'ukraine allait
tomber que kiev allait se rendre mais
finalement c'est pas ça puisque les
factures le bas la nation ukrainienne
existe alors justement un ancien
ambassadeur de france en russie jean de
gliniasty dit on assiste en ce moment la
naissance d'une nation est finalement
poutine en envahissant l'ukraine va
solidifier sous 17 cette nation ultra
direct qui tire sur ses frères en
réalité bah oui parce que ce sont des
peuples qui sont très proches ils
parlent pratiquement la même langue
beaucoup de familles sont se sont se
sont créés franco ukrainiens et russes
je pense que ce mouvement vers l'europe
vers la démocratie est en marche déjà
depuis longtemps ça commence en 2004
avec la révolution orange après 2014 il
ya le mouvement maidan et laon
on voit bien que le peuple ukrainien a
retrouvé sa fierté sa dignité son
président que ont trouvé un peu ridicule
au début ancien humoriste finalement
fait preuve d'un grand courage une
grande dignité représente son pays enfin
c'est impressionnant mais le prix à
payer va être terrible et c'est un
bouleversement je dirais du monde qui
est en train de se produire parce que
tout ça aura des conséquences et est ce
que poutine sous-estimé c'était aussi la
rue la réaction de l'union européenne
elle est restée unie et soudée et la
réaction de l'occident et en particulier
des pays membres de l'otan c'est du
jamais vu ben non et puis une routine
pensaient au contraire que l'occident
était faible et que s'ils allaient
pouvait en profiter mais finalement il
ya cette réponse qui est je crois
également pour lui il sans doute
étonnante et déstabilisant beaucoup de
pays beaucoup de pays notamment l'union
européenne les pays baltes par exemple
mais bien d'autres sont évidemment très
inquiet le premier ministre polonais
disait l'autre jour dans un entretien à
ouest france oui nous craignons que kiel
qu'un jour ils passent la frontière ils
fassent aussi la frontière polonaise
est-ce que vous avez cette crainte là
est ce que vous pensez que on est au
début d'un processus qui pourrait aller
jusque là il ya une menace est
d'ailleurs lui-même à employer des
formules extrêmement violente et
extrêmement brutal il a augmenté le
niveau d' alerte des forces nucléaires
il est dans la menace après la question
du passage à l'acte moi je ne peux pas
le prédire mais ce qu'il a fait là
récemment nous montre qu'il est
dangereux qui n'a pas peur de la
violence et qu'il ait marqué par cette
conception de l' usage de la violence
pour agir que ce soit sur le plan
politique ce soit sur le plan militaire
donc il faut se méfier donc il faut
s'organiser et tenir bon et notamment
renforcer notre défense et en
particulier le défenseur de la violence
contre les civils parce que ce qui est
fou évidemment c'est qu'on a
l'impression que il est prêt à tous les
coups on a le cul de retenue à l'égard
des six mois j'ai l'expérience aussi de
ce qui s'est passé en syrie
quand obama a refusé finalement de de
suivre la france pour réagir par des
frappes ciblées en uc en syrie lorsque
l'usagé des armes chimiques a été
prouvée
poutine en a profité et s'est insérée
dans le conflit syrien et après on a vu
avec quelle brutalité avec les moyens
notamment d'aviation il a bombardé les
positions des opposants à bachar al
assad et et là on a assisté je me
souviens des biens de réunions
auxquelles j'ai participé y compris à
moscou y compris dans une rencontre avec
lui combien c'était très difficile
d'obtenir des couloirs humanitaires pour
permettre d'aider les populations
civiles donc là ce qui serait urgent
c'est d'obtenir un cessez le feu c'est
ce qu'a demandé l'assemblée générale des
nations unies et puis de mettre en place
des couloirs humanitaires pour sauver la
population civile on va voir mais c'est
cet aspect désespéré cette tentative
mais il faut quand même l'essayer
l'attenté jean marc ayrault notre invité
ce matin l'ancien premier ministre sur
ce plateau un dessinateur et
collaborateurs de ouest-france bien
connu vous connaissez chaunu à une
question à vous poser sous forme de
dessin on regarde enfin cette semaine
les masques sont tombés et on va pouvoir
retrouver avec plaisir les expressions
du visage pour les moins expressif
d'entre nous comme vladimir poutine de
la tchétchénie à la crimée en passant
par la géorgie at on besoin qu'il retire
son masque pour connaître ses réelles
intentions
françois xavier le franc on va parler là
j'ai pas si on pouvait connaître ses
réelles intentions puisque ce que vous
avez posé la question des buts
l'émission
moi je pensais que poutine aurait comme
objectif
de prendre dombass après la
reconnaissance des républiques
autoproclamées
qu'il avait armé avec les milices
patriotiques de ces territoires mais en
fait il est allé beaucoup plus loin
parce que c'est toute l'ukraine qui veut
faire tomber en disant que le grain est
une fiction je pense que ce qu'il faut
faire c'est relire le discours de
poutine lorsque le lundi il ya huit
jours le le poutine fait un discours
pseudo historique il explique en fait
cette analyse de l'histoire qui est une
aucune du révisionnisme historique mais
c'est la base de son raisonnement et qui
justifient en quelque sorte son action
dans un premier temps on le voit sur le
plan militaire la ce qu'il est en train
de faire c'est de relier
la crimée au donbass alors justement
d'allemands militaire une question sur
l'allemagne un pays que vous connaissez
intimement je rappelle que vous étiez
avant de faire la politique professeur
d'allemand le chancelier allemand a
annoncé une décision est très
spectaculaire dont l'investissement de
100 milliards d'euros pour pour
améliorer la l'armée allemande renforcer
l'armée allemande il a également
expliqué que l'allemagne serait au-delà
de 2% de son produit intérieur brut dans
les investissements militaires c'est une
décision réellement historique ça oui
parce que l'allemagne était assez
frileuses sur cette question notamment
de d 2 % de son budget pour de son pib
pour financer la défense c'est au delà
de ce que demande l'otan c'est non il va
t'il il a rappelé que c'était 2% mais il
a mis surtout en place un fonds
d'investissement de 100 milliards
d'euros acquis et un budget annexe du
budget fédéral et qui a pour objectif de
d'avis de financer les investissements
qui sont des investissements pour
remettre à niveau la bundeswehr qui est
quand même en pas en très bon état pour
jouer son rôle pleinement
lanka d'attac et puis également de
participer à des programmes européens il
ya un programme un projet européen
franco allemand d'avion il ya un projet
européen et franco-allemand de chat donc
c'est une accélération dont vue du don
qu'il se donne les moyens d'être à la
hauteur des engagements que l'allemagne
avait quand même pris avant certains
parlent de réarmement d'allemagne s'agit
pas d'un réarmement de l'allemagne il
simple il s'agit simplement que
l'allemagne fasse son devoir dans le
cadre de l'otan et de l'alliance
atlantique renforcement de la défense
européenne finalement c'est ce corps a
provoqué poutine alors c'est ça c'est ça
qui est de 16 ans c'est l'effet inverse
au fond de ce qu'ils voulaient oui bien
entendu mais il pensait que nous allions
nous déchirer nous diviser et c'est pas
ce qui s'est produit par contre
effectivement nous ne sommes qu'au début
de la défense européenne là j'ai donné
quelques exemples on va y venir y ont
fait ensemble mais je pense que c'est la
priorité politique d avis mais jean marc
ayrault d'y parvenir et avec l'otan en
plus d'avoir nos capacités propres
européennes notre partenaire du groupe
centre france la montagne
antoine compagne qui est journaliste
aliaune républicaine à une question à
vous poser concernant le processus
d'adhésion de l'ukraine à l'union
européenne on écoute bonjour jean marc
ayrault
lundi le président ukrainien volodimir
zielinski a signé un document de
candidature d'adhésion à l'union
européenne la veille c'était la
présidente de la commission européenne
où seul à van der leyen qui avait
soutenu cette démarche alors est-ce que
selon vous cette le processus qui vient
s'enclencher a des chances d'aboutir
rapidement comme le demande le président
ukrainien mais aussi est-ce que selon
vous cette démarche est légitime ou
plutôt symbolique dans une dynamique
d'union sacrée je pense que le président
un ski a rappelé l'attachement des
ukrainiens à l'europe ils l'ont montré
je les ai rappelés tout à l'heure mais
ça se fait pas comme ça d' adhérer à
l'union européenne il ya tout un
processus il ya d'autres pays l'ont déjà
candidat à la serbie monténégro et ça va
faire déjà dix ans donc il ya la géorgie
qui c'est un acte politique de la part
de l'ukraine et je pense que l'europe ne
peut pas dire oui bien sûr rentrer ça va
se faire comme ça c'est compliqué mais
je pense qu'il faut entamer un dialogue
interne et un dialogue et surtout pas
donner l'impression que la porte est
complètement fermée mais ça ne se fera
pas de toute façon de façon automatique
et ultra rapide mais est-ce qu'on peut
rester dans cet entre deux finalement la
question de la frontière elle de l'union
européenne elle et elle est posée est-ce
qu'il faut pas aujourd'hui la renforcer
dire clairement les choses l'irl à
l'europe commence ici oui mais bon
attendez il faut où il faut quand même
faire les choses avec méthode et avec
rigueur il ya une frontière de l'union
européenne qui est à la frontière
polonaise à l'est et nous sommes membres
de l'otan donc il n'a jamais été
envisagé que la l'ukraine entre dans
l'otan tout cas ce n'était pas la
position unis de la france et de
l'allemagne je pense que c'était une
bonne position mais je rappelle qu'il ya
quand même un accord d'association entre
l'union européenne et l'ukraine et les
ukrainiens il tenait beaucoup donc il
faut faire vivre ça et là il ya
l'urgence il ya l'aide humanitaire il ya
tout ce que les aides militaires tout ce
que l'europe et les pays européens
peuvent déjà faire et ce qu'ils sont en
train de faire et je pense que ça ce
sont des signaux qui sont donnés aux
ukrainiens l'accueil les réfugiés c'est
très important mais vire et chaque pays
doit il prendre sa part bien sûr la
france aussi d'accord et c'est donc là
dessus qu'il faut évidemment porter les
efforts et l'aller
les populations civiles de l'union
européenne sont évidemment concernées
est fortement mobilisée absolument
absolument c'est tout à fait rassurant
parce que l'on revoie les débats
franco-français sur l'immigration là
d'un seul coup on a l'impression que
tout est en train d'être remis en cause
et que tous ceux qui ont peur sont en
train de dire il faut être solidaire et
ils ont raison il faut être solidaire je
dois dire que jean marc ayrault mady
avant cette émission que la première
chose qu'il faisait le matin s'étaient
regardés l'appli de ouest france sur le
numérique la une de ouest france
françois xavier le tort elle est
consacrée évidemment à l'invasion de
l'ukraine par la russie il rappelle
également dans l'éditorial une chose
c'est que en 2014 il y avait eu des
mesures de rétorsion contre l'ukraine ça
a amené poutine investir 200 milliards
dans son agriculture et la russie est
aujourd'hui le premier exportateur
mondial de blé et donc quand il l'est
subit des pressions de ce type
finalement il utilise là pour renforcer
son économie c'est ce qu'il a fait avec
l'agriculture ont là le salon de
l'agriculture en ce moment et c'est un
trek augmenter sa oui bien sûr c'est ce
qui se passe c'est aussi ce qui est
important c'est de rappeler c'est que
les européens avec les américains et les
canadiens se sont mis d'accord très très
très vite ils compris les japonais
coréens sur des sanctions qui sont d'un
niveau inégalé jusqu'à présent et qui
vont faire mal à la russie et qui auront
des conséquences mais qui en aussi pour
nous il faut en être conscient qui est
sur le prix de l'énergie sur toute une
série de la consommation etc et donc je
le président macron d'ailleurs l'a dit
hier soir je pense qu'il faut pas avoir
peur de se donner les moyens en tant
qu'européens et en tant que français ou
allemand enfin les membres de l'union
européenne pour faire face à cette ses
conséquences économiques pour nous il
faut pas qu évidemment les français les
européens soient victimes le quoi qu'il
en coûte de la pandémie je pense qu'il
faut qu'on l'appliqué aussi dans cette
période jean marc ayrault est notre
invité ce matin merci françois xavier le
franc dans un instant laurent marchand
et sur ce plateau
[Musique]
bonjour laurent marchand merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes éditorialiste à
ouest france et vous êtes également
spécialiste des questions
internationales
c'est la guerre de poutine aussi oui
bonjour monsieur le ministre la guerre
de poti nous avait évoqué son discours
du lundi 21 février dans lequel il
daignait aux ukrainiens le rang même de
nation jusqu'où peut-il aller dans cette
vision puisqu'il faut le prendre au mot
manifestement puisque vous désirez on ne
s'y attendait pas comme la plupart
d'ailleurs dès les observateurs ont été
surpris qu'il aille au delà du nom basse
à quoi faut-il s'attendre
on n'imaginait pas tout ça et finalement
ça s'est quand même produit donc il faut
être sur nos gardes il faut mettre la
barre haut pour être ferme sur les
principes bien dire qui est responsable
de ce qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est
poutine poutine lui poutine seul à qui a
décidé de faire la guerre à une pays
frère qui est laquelle l'ukraine en
niant son existence en traitant ses
dirigeants de nazis ou de drogués
unanimité de ce conte c'est autour de
lui ça je ne sais pas je ne sais pas
parce que c'est un système très
verrouillé très fermé où l'opinion
publique
existe mais la liberté de la presse
n'existe plus la liberté de se réunir
l'association n'ont plus regardé le le
forum de la mémoire des victimes du
stalinisme qui vient d'être interdit
donc il ya la volonté de museler le
peuple pourtant le peuple russe réagi et
je crois que le peuple russe et
profondément pacifique il a trop subi la
guerre vous pensez qu'il peut peser dans
ce que je pense qu'à bord ya les
sanctions qui vont avoir un effet que ça
commence et puis il ya la communication
ce que font les ukrainiens le président
ukrainien s'adressant aux russes qui est
sa langue maternelle d'ailleurs assez
voisin russe
c'est quelque chose qui pèse parce que
il ya certes l'opinion muselet mais il
ya quand même les réseaux sociaux il ya
des communications les gens se téléphone
s'est pas fermé
quand pour qu'on pourrait l'imaginer
hermétique non et puis il ya ce courage
des gens qui vont manifester alors
certes il ya beaucoup de prix 2002 jean
mis en tension plusieurs milliers de
personnes mais je pense que ce mouvement
doit être encouragée par ce que il est
aussi la dignité du peuple russe qui ne
se laisse pas faire jusqu'où nous
pouvons nous aller voulons nous aller si
il y ait un incident avec les pays
baltes des avions réussi hier ont violé
l'espace aérien suédois
nous pouvons entrer en guerre d'un
moment à l'autre si les paysans de
remettre la guerre il faut vous être
faut être sincère mais mais mais sens
qu'il faut que pouteille être au visage
que les membres de l'otan
l'alliance atlantique il ya cet article
5 cet article 5 est très clair et que
quand un pays est attaqué les autres le
défendre c'est la solidarité et sa
l'appui de la pologne et les pays baltes
sont concernés il est aussi donc et nous
sommes concernés bien entendu donc il
faut que notre message politique qui ait
sur un mot clé et aujourd'hui j'ai
salaire il il est clair et il est clair
et il n'est pas seulement français il
est aussi allemande il est aussi
européens écouter ce que dit madame von
der leyen par exemple il est américain
il est canadien il est japonais et les
coréens fin bref enfin regarder
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
qui réclame le cessez le feu qui réclame
le retrait des troupes russes de de
l'ukraine donc c'est une majorité
écrasante avec simplement cinq pays qui
se sont opposés un relatif silence des
américains monde au début de set
certes l invasion pas et donne n'a pas
été très présent bah écoutez je pense
que d'abord les les américains ont fait
comme les français les allemands ont
parlé avec poutine ce qu'avait fait by
dunham à genève et puis ils ont passé
des messages
anthony blinken le ministre des affaires
étrangères secrétaires d'état américain
a rencontré son homologue lavrov s'est
et puis il ya eu les informations que
les américains ont donné au monde entier
ils étaient bien renseignés sur ce qui
était en train de se préparer les
surfactants condamnation au moment où
tina argué qu'ils pouvaient passer à la
dissuasion nucléaire on a trouvé que les
américains est un peu timorée on n'a pas
eu de réaction immédiate de la maison
blanche a pris du temps normal ce qui
compte sinon à réaxer l'unité
des occidentaux qui est extrêmement
solide forte il faut qu'elle soit
durable il faut que l'on soit bien
conscient qu'on est en train de changer
d'air et comment le monde va-t-il
évoluer comment les rapports de force
dont il évolue et comment les alliances
moutel évoluer la place de la chine qui
reste discrète pour l'instant mais vous
verrez à venir flâner style la question
de l'intérêt bilité des frontières la
question de l'énergie la question de la
technologie à toutes ces questions sont
sur la table dont on parlait de la
propagande en russie
il ya eu de la propagande russe en
france également ce conflit est présent
dans la société française de diverses
manières l'interdiction de russia today
et de spoutnik est un élément mais ce
n'est pas le seul trois des quatre
premiers candidats dans les sondages ont
été indulgents voire dé soutien de
poutine
c'est un problème démocratique français
d'abord c'est un problème démocratique
c'est verizon la liberté d'exprimer
leurs convictions mais on voit ce
qu'elles sont ces convictions c'est des
convictions de complaisance avec poutine
certains faisait même un modèle latin
candidats et d'autres continuent de dire
il faut qu'on sorte de l'otan qu'est ce
que ça veut dire aujourd'hui sortir de
l'otan comment protège-t-on la france
comme on protège ton l'europe c'est pas
très sérieux donc le lire elle est la
vérité est en train d'éclater et avec
certains sincère mais d'autres camps
doute avec des arrières pensées mais
qu'imaginait que l'ennemi principal
c'est l'américain je pense qu'il faut
quand même devenir sérieux aujourd'hui
l'otan s'est renforcé et c'est une bonne
chose il faut maintenant que le
complément soit la défense européenne
qui soit a également développé ces c'est
ça qui nous avons faire et donc là nous
sommes venus au moment des
clarifications politique en interne
après je terminerai en disant une chose
avec le peuple russe et notre ami et que
nous nous souhaitons des relations
d'amitié de coopération avec la russie
c'est pas notre adversaire la russie
prison de mâcon l'adil tout à fait
raison jean marc ayrault denis carreaux
qui est directeur des rédactions du
groupe nice matin à une question à vous
poser on les écoute depuis son studio
magnifique vous allez voir d'ailleurs à
nice angers
bonjour jean marc ayrault les premiers
réfugiés ukrainien commencent à arriver
en france c'est le cas dans les
alpes-maritimes où le président du
département charles ange ginésy se
propose d'aider au rapatriement de mille
réfugiés et de les héberger est-ce qu'il
a raison le faire et jusqu'où la france
doit-elle prendre sa part c'est
l'expression du président de la
république pour l'accueil des réfugiés
ukrainien qui vont arriver par milliers
dans les jours qui viennent il ya une
concertation européenne qui va dans le
bon sens il te dire qu'avec la la
volonté de tous les pays d'accueillir
des réfugiés l'ukrainien et de deux de
jouer le jeu de la solidarité de
répartir la l'accueil parce que c'est
vrai que ça se fera pas comme ça de
façon simple il faut se donner les
moyens de sa et donc ça contraste avec
ce qui s'est passé par rapport aux
réfugiés syriens oui l'opinion publique
française a l'air beaucoup plus
favorable mais louis l'union européenne
donc c'est une leçon qu'il faut tirer
j'espère que ça aidera à avoir une
politique plus concertée plus
coopérative et plus solidaire sur ces
questions migratoires à l'échelle de
l'europe en tout cas là il ya un élan de
générosité solidarité qui est un élan
populaire c'est sans les gens les
français de toutes opinions de toutes
sensibilités de toutes régions qui sont
des communes ont fait des propositions
donc on va dans la bonne direction c'est
la solidarité revenons à l'otan la
france a décidé de renforcer le flanc
sud-est de l'otan en europe en roumanie
en prenant même la responsabilité de
certains bataillon il faut aller plus
loin selon vos puisqu'on compte encore
en milliers la présence militaire dans
ces pays c'est très peu si ces terres
que l'otan qui fait peur poutine à l'ars
pige joue à se faire peur je pense qu'en
grande partie celle au-delà mais l'otan
d'abord c'est une organisation défensive
et non pas
offensive et et menaçante mais quand on
regarde la réalité de nos capacités
sont pas si énorme que ça c'est pas des
centaines de milliers de soldats qui
sont dans des casernes ou dans des camps
dans des camps et manuellement l'otan
est en état de mort clinique il a oui
mais c'est plus le cas si 6 il 6 à u pu
l être dans le passé je ne sais pas si
c'est vrai en tout cas c'est ce qu'il
avait dit aujourd'hui tout le monde ne
reconnaît que l'otan existe et l'otan se
renforce mais c'est vrai que la présence
en termes de moyens matériels militaires
et humain reste à compléter sur une
partie du continent européen donc c'est
ce qui a contribué à faire la france ce
que fait l'allemagne aussi dans les pays
baltes et en pologne et en roumanie
françois-xavier lefranc évoqué la
question de la frontière de l'europe est
ce que quand on rentre dans les
questions stratégiques
cette question ne doit pas faire
justement l'objet d'une plus grande
étude plus précise écoutez je pense
qu'il faut
être très très prudent la frontière les
frontières de l'union européenne existe
aujourd'hui c'est notamment sentir à
l'aise avec la pologne les pays baltes
la roumanie la bulgarie
et on joue pas avec les frontières et
poutine a remis en cause la stabilité de
la paix de après la seconde guerre
mondiale la question de la fronde des
frontières est une question difficile
vous souvenez entre l'allemagne et la
france l'allemagne de l'est et
l'allemagne de l'ouest après la
réunification la question était reposé
de la frontière avec la pologne mais
c'est la frontière qui est sorti de
seconde guerre mondiale qui finalement a
été respecté c'est une bonne chose donc
je dis attention ne jouons pas avec les
frontières et s'était notamment les
accords d'helsinki de 1975 qui avait
rappelé que ses frontières ne devait
absolument en aucun cas être remises en
cause et tous les signataires du traité
dont la russie à elle à l'union
soviétique à l'époque avait dit on n'y
touchera pas ici les rugiens kadouch si
la russie tous puisque il n'a pas tenu
sa parole sur simplement là là il ne
sait pas vraiment qui touche à la
frontière il l'avait touché en attaque
andré silva la touche en estonie amellal
c'est ceci on a dit tout à l'heure mais
c'est l'article 5 du traité atlantique 2
de l'alliance atlantique du traité de
l'otan mais personne ne souhaite aller
jusque là mais il faut que ce soit très
très clair le les membres de l'otan ne
se laisseront pas faire et assureront la
sécurité de leurs peuples c'est ça le
message est que poutine doit entendre et
en même temps nous nous adressons à
poutine de messages que nous sommes
prêts même si la voix est ténu à
reprendre la négociation et le dialogue
par la voie diplomatique et en
commençant par le cessez-le-feu et
l'aide humanitaire c'est urgent c'est
fondamental et ça doit rester aussi
notre préoccupation merci laurent
marchand éditorialiste à ouest france
spécialiste des questions
internationales
jean marc ayrault est notre invité ce
matin vous avez été premier ministre
vous avez été mise des affaires
étrangères
lequel de ces deux fonctions vous a le
plus passionné assez difficile de faire
une hiérarchie parce que j'ai fait
beaucoup d'autres choses j'étais maire
de nantes pendant bien sûr 3 entraînants
souvenir d'ailleurs parlementaire
j'ai une vie politique très très riche
donc j'ai une insuffisance et deux
postes qui sont au sommet de l'état le
nom mais le plus passionnant le premier
ministre numéro deux de l'état ou avec
le qui fait un mois mais un duo avec le
président de la république c'est à la
fois écrasant et passionnant j'ai aimé
le faire mais j'ai beaucoup apprécié
aussi l'expérience des affaires
étrangères on dit que vous avez beaucoup
regretté de quitter matignon c'est vrai
oui mais bon puis pas de regrets et vous
savez c'était j'ai eu la chance de
pouvoir
assurer cette fonction c'est un honneur
je le prends comme tel j'ai aimé servir
mon pays je le fais d'une autre façon
aujourd'hui on va en parler et je crois
que c'est c'est l'essentiel
jean marc ayrault est notre invité dans
un instant sylvia garcia sur ce plateau
merci à laurent marchand merci
[Musique]
jean marc ayrault on va parler toujours
de questions internationales bien sur
cydia garcia avec les conséquences sur
le continent africain de scènes de
guerre bonjour effectivement l'image à
marquer enfin plusieurs images mais une
en particulier une femme nigérienne avec
son bébé obligé de céder la place dans
un bus pour fuir les combats est ce que
c'est une double peine pour les
africains qui sont là bas est ce qu'en
effet c'est comme le disait comme le
dénonce l'union africaine un traitement
raciste écoutez ce que cette femme a
ressenti oui c'est un traitement assista
alors à presque est-ce que c'est
généralisé c'est cette ça doit être
vérifiée six médailles en ski l'union
africaine j'ai bien vu la déclaration d'
union africaine et ils ont raison d'être
vigilant car il ya des témoignages qui
montrent que les choses n'ont pas été
correctes les gares notamment de ses
étudiants
africains qui voulaient rentrer chez eux
qu'ils voulaient
en passant par la pologne
il mérite d'être accueilli autant que
les autres donc en tout cas de ma part
il y aura une extrême vigilance pour que
les droits de l'homme soient respectés
pour que tous et toutes alors sur
l'évasion à proprement parler peu de
réactions en afrique un communiqué assez
laconique de l'union africaine là encore
et puis hier soir 35 abstentions sur la
résolution de l'assemblée générale de
l'onu la moitié 17 viennent du continent
pourquoi ce silence
écoutez je crois que il ya aussi les
résultats là d'une stratégie russe de
stratégie de poutine en afrique
n'oublions pas ce qui se passe au mali
n'oublions pas ce qui se passe en
centrafrique mais vous faites référence
qui sont en centrafrique et qui sont
allés quand on interroge quand les jours
quand vous journalisme s'interroger
poutine dans ses conférences de presse
sur la présence de wagner dans tel ou
tel pays dit mais moi je connais pas
mais alors qu'on sait très bien ce
wagner sont des troupes supplétifs qui
sont d'ailleurs qui sont en me traîne
qui en ont peut-être des démissions
terrible pour assassiner le président
ukrainien ou d'autres dirigeants donc ce
sont des forces supplétives utilisé par
bach ou steam donc elles agissent en
afrique à une stratégie de représente
parce que l'union soviétique sont
estimés par les européens ou par à
sous-estimer c'était en levant
l'observait mais il y aurait beaucoup de
choses à dire je pense que dans dans
l'avenir
c'est une des responsabilités de
l'europe d'être beaucoup plus solidaire
de l'afrique et pas seulement en terme
de sécurité de lutte contre le
terrorisme mais aussi en termes de
développement en train de soutien aux
états africains qui ont
des inspirations
courmayeur par des lectures du monde
peut-être qu'ils sont faites aussi qui
s'affrontent aujourd'hui également sur
le continent africain sur les réseaux
est ce qu'il appelle la tradition de non
alignement des pays africains qui
explique aussi cette position possible
c'est possible mais moi je pense qu'il
faut bien comprendre que certains pays
africains sont face à de grandes
difficultés
regardez regardez la guerre en ethiopie
regardez aussi les situations de famine
regarder la pauvreté de madagascar je
pense que il faut qu'on soit bien
conscient contre on ne peut pas laisser
faire cette finale mais dans tous les
cas besoin mais même sans choisir un
camp est ce que l'afrique va payer le
prix de la guerre en ukraine est ce que
la russie va devoir revoir sa politique
aussi en afrique pas je pense que la
politique de poutine qui consiste à
envoyer ses forces supplétives pour
aussi négocier et pillé certaine
richesse du pays dss minière notamment
en centrafrique où ou ou en en mali je
pense que c'est une question grave et
donc la question africaine la solidarité
avec les pays africains qui sont
certains sont déstabilisés où il ya eu
des coups d'état doit être à l'ordre du
jour une relation beaucoup plus étroite
et intense et solidaire entre l'union
européenne et les pays africains jean
marc ayrault pas seulement la france l
affaire de tous les européens jean marc
ayrault les taux les regards se
tournaient également vers la chine
abstention au conseil de sécurité lors
du vote d'une résolution condamnant
moscou et hier encore abstentions est ce
que il ya une prise de distance
aujourd'hui entre pékin vis-à-vis de
moscou bah il ya quand même cette
déclaration commune poutine chez jean
ping 4 février le début des jeux
olympiques on va bien trois semaines
quatre semaines plus tard la chine est
toujours un pays prudent observe ce qui
se passe ces intérêts a vendu ses
intérêts sa stabilité avant tout aussi
est-ce que les même temps il faut passer
de route de la soie sont compromises
aujourd'hui c'est est ce que c'est ce
qui inquiète je pense que la chine
n'aime pas tout ce qui déstabilise la
déstabilise et qui déstabilise le reste
du monde elle défend ses intérêts elle a
une vision stratégique autour de ses
intérêts et donc là elle est en position
d'observation au fond je ne sais pas
quel pas comment il va évoluer en tout
cas il faut puisque je de valoriser tout
à l'heure l'action diplomatique faut
continuer à parler très étroitement avec
chinois est ce que ces sanctions contre
la russie qui produisent en effet on
voit et qui est en effet assez rapide
est-ce que ça va jeter la russie dans
les bras de la chine est ce que la chine
va accueillir la russie les bras ouverts
on le verra on peut pas dire là en
réalité si je reformule c'est l'histoire
d'un nouveau bloc qui serait peut-être
en train d'émerger sa tête mais c'est
pas certain non plus les intérêts
pourraient être divergents entre la
chine et la russie à un moment donné à
court terme qui peut y avoir cette
solidarité à long terme on est en train
d'assister à nouvelle donne mondiale je
le disais tout à l'heure il ya des
grands sujets la question énergétique la
question du réchauffement climatique
faudrait pas qu'on les oublie elle est
toujours à l'ordre du jour le gic
sensations à bord c'est fondamental la
question de la technologie un du
numérique de la cité du contrôle aussi
de ceux de la question
la question des questions fondamentales
qui se posent à l'humanité aujourd'hui
pour son devenir je pense que
aujourd'hui tout est en train de changer
et les américains plutôt reculé dans
leur jeu de puissance mondiale et donc
ça veut dire encore une vie watts encore
une fois que la responsabilité des
européens alors là ils sont face à
l'histoire c'est vraiment de se
renforcer une hydre s'est pas seulement
économiquement mais se renforcer
politiquement et stratégiquement jean
marc ayrault une dernière question la
réaction occidentale envers la russie
est ce que c est ce qu elles servent
aussi d'avertissement à la chine mais
souvent évoqué une troisième guerre
mondiale qui démarrait en gare de chine
tu t'es et franchement tout doit être
fait pour empêcher la guerre mondiale
qui se tourne catastrophe et en
particulier avec l'armé nucléaire mais
c'est un avertissement je crois
important à l'humanité entière on ne
peut pas laisser faire ce qui est en
train de se passer en russie et en
ukraine aujourd'hui parce que les
conséquences sont incalculables est
particulièrement dangereuse donc c'est
notre responsabilité notamment aux
européens aux occidentaux de prendre des
positions claires et nettes mais en même
temps avec un objectif majeur qui est
celui de la paix merci sylvia garcia à
tv5monde de la rédaction emmanuel macron
jean marc ayrault vous a nommé en 2018
président de la fondation pour la
mémoire de l'esclavagé par une main pas
nommé j'ai été élu par le conseil
d'administration devait se poser à deux
rives l'avait été voilà élu par le
présent par le conseil ministration
pardonnez moi donc le directeur
éditorial de france antilles qui est
notre partenaire à une question à vous
poser depuis fort de france en
martinique on écoute sur ce sujet jean
marc ayrault vous êtes le président de
la fondation pour la mémoire de
l'esclavagé on s'aperçoit notamment en
période de campagne présidentielle qu'il
est parfois difficile pour le pays de
faire face à son passé comment selon
vous traiter les questions mémorielles
sans aggraver davantage les divisions et
bien la fondation pour la mémoire de
l'esclavagé rendus publics ces derniers
jours un questionnaire qui va adresser à
tous les candidats ce qu'ils vont avoir
leur parrainage dans quelques jours où
on va leur demander de se positionner
par rapport à cette histoire qui est
l'histoire de la france qui est pas
seulement l'histoire des eaux de nos
outre mer et des ultramarins qu'est
l'histoire française
l'histoire de la traite de l'esclavagé
de la colonisation et qui fait partie de
notre histoire que nous devons regarder
en face et donc notamment pose la
question est-ce que vous si vous êtes
élu président de la république vous
continuerez de commémoré chaque année le
10 et 23 mai le souvenir de cette
histoire est-ce que vous continuerez à
faire en sorte que cette histoire soit
enseignée dans les programmes scolaires
est-ce que vous continuerez à agir pour
lutter contre les discriminations le
racisme et toutes ces questions sont
donc ces dix points que nous avons nous
allons adresser aux candidats à
l'élection présidentielle dont nous
propose nous propose profitons de ce
moment pour une clarification est donc
là on va voir on verra ce qu'ils pensent
que cette histoire c'est l'histoire de
toute la france et notre histoire jean
marc ayrault vous avez été le dernier
premier ministre de la gauche unie qu'on
appelait la gauche plurielle l'appeler
comme ça est ce que vous vous désole
aujourd'hui de voir l'état de lagos
cette multiplicité de candidats
je rappelle que vous avez été le premier
ministre de christiane tout bien qui
était votre ministre de la justice qui
vient donc de déclarer qu'elle renonçait
à l'élection présidentielle elle n'a pas
réuni les 500 signatures nécessaires
quelle est votre analyse sur cette
gauche qui a explosé ben je suis triste
et consterné parce que ce que porte la
gauche comme ideo les droits de l'homme
la justice sociale la paix dont ces
grands grande grands principes
la capacité à nous projeter dans un
destin commun ce sont des idéaux qui
sont qui parle qui ont du sens
aujourd'hui et qui sont pas dépassées on
vous a pas entendu en soutien d'anne
hidalgo qui en détiennent du parti
social il viendra à notre succès c'est
arnaud donckele à lui s'est prononcé
elle viendra andreï dynko jour je serai
là pour la saluer pour l'accueillir bien
entendu moi je suis socialiste je reste
socialiste mais je suis consterné par
l'état de la gauche donc aujourd'hui la
gauche il ya des désaccords mais les
valeurs fondamentales de la gauche
devrait être générée sur la table
commune un axe d'orientation et l'action
possible et pourquoi ce n'est pas le cas
je pense que la gauche doit se
réinterroger elle doit se reconstruire
se refonder et ce temps sera sans doute
assez long vous voulez faire partie de
ceux qui vont réfléchir belle raconte
certaine façon j'ai contribué mais je
suis plus dans la politique active je
pense qu'il est important aussi que de
nouvelles générations prennent la relève
et moi j'ai ce que j'ai fait à nantes
j'ai préparé ma la relève avec johanna
rolland qui est que nous avons
accueillis sur ce bien sûr et je m'en
réjouis et j'aimerais que au fond on
fasse une place à ceux qui peuvent
incarner qui peut l'incarner je vais y
en a plein qui peuvent être des noms qui
vous viennent non je ne donnerai pas de
nom parce que je pense qu'il faudra du
temps beaucoup de temps mais que ça
viendra du terrain nous sommes face aux
territoires et quand je regarde ce qui
se passe dans nos territoires nos
villages nos communes nos villes je
pense qu'il ya un espoir mais faut quand
caen voilà qui font un renouvellement
quand vous voyez françois hollande qui a
été le président de la république qui
vous a nommé premier ministre en thé
d'intervenir dans la campagne serait ce
qu'il est dans son rôle où est-ce qu'ils
devraient pas là vous vous m'interrogez
là que je donne mon point de vue e-mail
et votre vision sur mais que fait
françois hollande aujourd'hui moi je
veux pas porter de jugement si là il à
son expérience dans la crise
internationale que nous connaissons ces
c'est utile mais je crois qu'il est en
même temps important que des têtes des
dom et devait faire un atout nouveau
prennent la relève et il y en a beaucoup
dans notre pays il ya beaucoup de
richesses et c'est comme ça le rend avec
emmanuel macron sont bons moi je
respecte le président de la république
et en ce moment il est
en première ligne j'ai écouté son
intervention hier soir que j'ai trouvé
de bonnes qualités et qui il a eu le ton
juste nantes en finale de la coupe de
france de football ça vous a fait
plaisir par bah oui ça rappelle moi ça
me rappelle de très bons souvenirs quand
j'ai été maire de nant pendant 23 ans
j'ai eu la chance de voir un entre les
champions de france plusieurs fois gagné
la coupe de france et donc hier soir
c'était un grand moment et je pense que
les nantais l'ont partagé avec moi mais
beaucoup d'autres qui aiment qu'ils ont
et la nostalgie du beau jeu à la
nantaise on vous voit peu dans les
médias merci d'avoir versé l'autre la
natation vraiment jean marc ayrault
ancien premier ministre ministre des
affaires étrangères et président de la
fondation pour la mémoire de l'esclavagé
les programmes continus sur tv5 monde
merci à vous et à très vite pour un
nouveau numéro de face aux territoires
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]